Dear viewers, curious minds and explorers of the world!
Do not miss us that many people - plus us -
They enjoy playing Pokemon Goo
It gives a sense of adventure, and goes out to explore the world and increase them all
But my dear friends, please do not forget the ookimans in real life
You know, like:
Pokemon electric, poisonous and watery
Watering
It is the only poisonous breast that can whiten
Do not forget to have electrical receptors to locate the frist
What about the most ambiguous,
Pokemon for the land of the blind: the raccoon
Uses high intelligence to remember solutions and tasks up to 3 years
* I remember this garbage * There are certainly a lot of rare bochemons around the planet as well.
Try searching for the Earthmind: the star-nosed mole
Who has 22 greasy plus in his nose
Hosts 25.000 sensory sensory receptors
Or a blue sea dragon from nude gills
Which floats upside down in the water
By surface tension and camouflage with water
This tree hopper is a rare bacterium and bacterium
With horn-like extensions or a helmet
And what is Pokemon?
Okay ! It's a bat fish, which is used
The flap of the bra to walk on the surface of the ocean
And something on his head to attract his prey
The charm of the Pokemon Goo is completely enchanting to your liking
You may not want to fight against a rhinoceros beetle
This fighter can lift a weight greater than 850 times
If you have this power, you can carry up to 2-8 servings
While hunting for Katrby, why not look for a drink
Amazing creatures that can transform from one shape to another
Many of them make metal-like crystals in this process
Find Baiji?
Look around you may see a dove too
This amazing bird can learn to differentiate every letter of spelling
Many of them have a unique ability to find their way home
Through vast areas using magnetic receptors
If you pass on the iPod,
It will never bother you to stop and check the local rocks
That you should actually lose some of them
These Pokemon have always been around us
That is why we are presenting the challenge of "Pokemon in real life"
Inspired by Ajant Marfi who invented the rules of this game
Simply find or choose an animal that inspires you
Analyze its strength and distinctive properties
Then share it with the world by HASH Taq (#pokemonIRL)
You get extra points if you take the picture yourself!
You found a creature during your adventure do not know it?
Take a photo and use the #PokeBlitz
In order to help others to know who is
Contribute to the publication of this section to inspire others in the natural world
We'll publish what's on Twitter and Instagram
So continue and feel your explorations
And subscribe to the channel for more scientific sections weekly